a poor Mumia my dad bought our first
house about eight years ago it's funny
because that house that I bought I just
because my dad when I was younger I said
I'll make sure you save me one India and
I wasn't on a lot of money when I was
growing up when I was at Lester Lester
he's now money but I saved what I had
and then we ended up buying this house
we rented that out and then I'm like
like one of you think one of your things
that we dad remortgaged it bought and
then built the house in Tanzania
no I we mortgaged again bought a piece
of land and at the minute we've got like
12 flats
yeah tons a near near they speak Swahili
yeah yes between a Jambo Jambo mumble
yeah coup de matar I guess really basic
yeah I speak I speak a bit yeah and then
in my own court in Tanzania he owns lots
of property not I mean and he's doing
nothing and I'm like I said I'm the most
hardworking person you probably ever
meet but I'm the laziest person in the
world so when I don't be lazy there dude
because if your footballer no no I mean
like obviously have a footballer yeah I
work I ask anyone who knows me I work
I'll do absolutely anything to be yes
but at the same time when I've only
thought what I don't want to do anything
yes not me not you just want to is that
because your whole life is like football
yeah and for you property and business
is kind of almost like a fantasy yeah
you like the idea of it yeah I mean I
just about you like you're doing you're
doing something that you love you're not
I mean yeah you're doing just helping
people ask what I do obviously I've got
the charity as well what charity do you
have I'm just helping orphans all I've
got like so 30 30 kids and then rented
out like a like a room like this so they
stay here eat sleep so I just hope that
in Tanzania intangible yeah yeah that's
awesome
so I also do what I can there so with
football then are you currently at your
peak of success or are you kind of like
what's going on it with you chrome or
things things going down or things going
up well if you're a spoke to me two
months ago I what I said probably when I
just signed for Blackpool
you have been the peak but I mean I see
with the manager
that things didn't work out in this
season but then I went and played
honestly if you don't ask me if we would
have this meeting
two months ago yeah I would have said we
spoke two months ago that's one way yeah
yeah that was when you and that was like
just time for Blackpool I've played in
African Cup of Nations yeah and that was
like so that happens every two for two
or four years or three years but I want
of welcome I've dreamt dreamt about yeah
five years ago
so I played enough combination and get a
move to Blackpool literally the dream
you know I mean and then bang managed to
get sacked a new manager comes in just
how Solihull compared to Blackpool
obviously there are two leaks below they
were in the conference Prem and Eisley
Blackpool in League One the ownership
team just got really gay are they in the
Premiership bubble no no no they got
relegated twice so they were in Ligue 1
now okay yeah yeah or is Ligue 1 just
below the Premiership yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay so now what what's what's the
next year yeah what's the next year
football why isn't it football wise wise
obviously get obviously do well at
Solihull because I'm there to adjourn
so hopefully go back to German get my
chance at Blackpool could offset my
chance yeah blackball so hopefully show
them that you're good show them that
Gord you not I mean
and then I believe you'll do that man Oh
hopefully that would be the dream and
then with the property thing I just want
to obviously invest some money happen a
minute I'm going through I bought em
okay it's crazy because I've been
watching you for about three or four
months for my friend who literally did
my for one of my friend just said and he
iPhone look at this guy man this guy's
from around your area could offset from
last time
yeah because I have a look at this guy's
sick my life so then obviously I thought
let me have a look I know I'm already I
was interested in it yeah so I had a
look at you and I was literally obsessed
about what till now literally last hours
watching it before I come to you and I
fall I you know what this this is this
is what I you know I mean at least I'll
be working obviously I'm talking I'm
thinking about after football at least
I'd be doing something that I enjoy I
enjoy going to a house
mm in a mess yeah and then slowly
getting I mean you know I mean I did
yeah you know I mean I just love seeing
stuff like that you know you're helping
people because I've seen ya giving them
a house I mean I'm you making money oh
yeah
so a little bit about my sort of setup
so on I invest in property and I train
property and under YouTube videos to
inspire people about property but I also
have fortunately it's not here today but
I can get him on the phone it's a
property director who heads up all of
our commercial side of stuff so we have
a guy who just goes out there finding
deals and all that so yeah you know if
you depending on what you're wanting to
do I can also not only kind of help you
and then give you advice and stuff like
that but I can also hook you up with the
the best brokers the best accountants if
you need that the best deal sources best
project managers you know mean so they
can kind of like oversee the project but
I mean like 100 percent me I've got
people good people around me that
obviously have more money than me so
yeah but the thing is I don't want to go
to them without education like I really
wanted to come to your course port and I
think it was just at Tommy's Friday
Saturday's not always usually what days
hard
Friday the worst days like train on
Fridays yeah
and then obviously the game on Saturday
yeah so like it's generally like
mutually impossible as an entrepreneur
you want to make money and then you want
to invest money you've got a scale where
you're able to make a lot of money it's
potentially yeah and also you've got all
the perks that go with that and the fame
which is a massive asset what you want
to do is you want to put everything into
that so I'd never say to you oh don't do
that
yeah I'm really bad advice yeah you
what's your name again sir Adi Adi Adi
you a day should be focusing on the
football solely making loads of money
but then in your part time and spare
time be educated and then invest that
money yeah
smartly with a team but you're right you
definitely want to be educated because
you don't want to you don't want to
invest money back then what you're doing
you want to be educated and also if
you're educated then you'll be able to
joint venture and race violence from
potentially a whole bunch of other this
is what I'm saying like I've got people
good people around me who have got money
I mean and then after football yeah a
lot more so no idea would because it the
pop if you're if you're wanting to bring
something to the table to all the
footballers the problem with footballers
have is that they have very little time
because they're all training themselves
yeah and playing football and and and
and very little knowledge and probably
not loads of contacts you have the same
problems yeah but if you can find a way
of solving those problems then you'll
become really valuable to all the others
what about if you found someone who I'm
this probably person probably wouldn't
be me but if you found someone who was
able to mentor you in proper say yeah
and I could even potentially connect you
to some people so when you don't
actually go to a training course you
could get one-on-one sort of support
yeah train train you up and then you
could do it to suit your diary yeah I
don't know no like I said one date like
what's fair see I reckon I could get
people just because of who you are your
positioning because you're a
professional football player just kind
of cool
they're big people that are making a lot
of money in property to you really well
they would probably love to mentor yeah
yeah because it's like it's on their CV
then isn't it my mentor a footballer
give them exposure to me
so I know people in poverty that are
making really good money they've been
trained by me they absolutely kicking
ass in property and they'd probably be
almost qualified to teach you as I would
yeah look they're brilliant and if they
could take you under their wing and
teach you they'd probably love the
opportunity even and I mean you've got
that loads of money even if they might
just say I want a percentage of the deal
or just come just cover my time me I'm
expensive
to me to sit down with me is is not it's
not cheap no I heard yeah so but but we
can potentially are very happy to help
think of something out what do you all
talk even won't be will be your dream
situation as in now or the future as in
over the next six six twelve months just
not relying on football money yes
like if something was to happen today I
can be alright because the football I
could obviously have signed a two plus
one a black ball book well in the end of
that I could be jobless that's a yeah
you know I mean so that's that's what I
am I just I just don't want to be I
don't want to rely on football money
that's the that's the aim what excites
you about probably white why property
just renovate just everything you keep
talking about renovation yeah honestly I
like seeing stuff that's from nothing to
something black yeah I've seen some of
your stuff like you've gone in and it's
an absolute bomb yeah and then six weeks
later yes
no I mean I love seen before and afters
and yeah yeah just a story in a house
yeah so so for instance I did you know
the BRR strategy no by Weaver [ __ ]
refinance yeah so you take the houses
rundown spend a bit of money on it add
value to it then refinance it like yeah
yeah but just on a smaller and where
would you want to do it you live in the
black ball
no not at the minute cuz I've see them
back slowly also I'm living at home in
Leicester doing it with you with the
type of job that you've got do you think
you might need a joint venture partner
to be hands and feet on the ground
because if you're moving here there and
everywhere
maybe you're going off to Tanzania then
move to your bloke named Lester if
you've got a project going on in that
pool but you're not there if you've got
a project Lester but you know that yeah
no I mean you stress thinking about it
and you're supposed to be doing again
when you're thinking on that or builders
are doing a good job that's the thing as
well because obviously I want to do into
property but at the same time the dream
is football becoming the best football
or can be you know I mean
oh yeah that's a busy dream no I mean
that is the dream and I've sit at the
same time the dream is to be financially
free hope yeah hope my dad hope mommy
family and everything else obviously
that's important as well if you make it
an absolute load of money in football if
some it takes off for the good and you
make a fortune can do you want I don't
think he would waste the money yeah
exactly I don't think you would reject
never never he doesn't know that kind of
person never liked the minute I'm going
through an appointment I'm getting I'm
buying an apartment or there's apartment
and so basically I've got a good friend
that works in an estate agent mmm and he
rang me up for about three months ago
and he said Eddie this is apartment this
woman is desperate to sell it like she's
struggling for money where's this in
Lester okay local as well yeah so
instead you interested cause the I told
him I'm interested in getting into
property so I've gone yeah and also have
checked like like some of the stuff you
said that I seemed like you check you
neighbor I sold and neighbor I sold the
flats were selling for like 105 this is
about two years ago as well when even
510 and she was she put up for like 89
yeah and I think he lost nearly 30 grand
us righty laughing and then I said to my
mate like what'd she take and he said
mate just dude she's desperate for the
money so put some in cheek in the
worst-looking she said like the where
she can say yeah so I put in an offer
over there what did I put the first one
I must have put like she puts she put a
489 and I pull out 69 mm-hmm and then I
thought I was embarrassed I was like I
was literally cringing our thinking our
mate
yeah she's desperate for money and I'm
just putting in SEO anyway I put in 60
Nash said no and then I've gone I think
to myself what what's the next
respective war force and I thought all
right 75 75 and then staged in couple of
days later said now she's not accepted
75 she lacks she's not gonna go anything
under 80 mm at least times I've already
viewed the house and I knew it needs a
new boiler and a new kitchen yeah so am
two days later I've said to Allah listen
there's a new boiler needs to be put in
a new kitchen like that's already five
grand
six TLC is not probably my probably get
one for like three four well said we
have six grand and I said listed my last
offer and I'm I can sort it out I've got
decision in principle so it everything
I'm ready to go my last offer
seventy-eight funny enough I went into
the I went into the letting agency
trying to get a better mortgage deal so
I was sat in the corner and I said
listen my last offer 78 like if she
doesn't want it she doesn't want I'll go
look at something else yeah and then she
came up to me and said there by the way
is 78 you like yep blast off what and
then she said all right well she wants
80 we're gonna do more viewings tomorrow
if you're not gonna accept 80 that's
fine gold teeth I remember you say just
let yeah and then literally 30 seconds
later she's gone
you know what she's accepted 78 oh nice
oh um yes I managed to get 478 and so
when did you buy that a year or two ago
no no no this is now oh this is just now
actually she accepted that because I
came back from Tanzania there we go
winners Wednesday story now literally
two days ago I've come back from
Tanzania he got accepted a week before
that so when I went to Tanzania I can't
we least sought the launch stuff so
literally I got back yeah into two days
ago
and when I signed all the stuff so
that's going through as we speak going
for the hold so hopefully and that's
unless there was what would the remedy
on that the rent is 600 pound a month I
can get that's not bad that's not I
think it's it's an apartment it's an
apartment two bedroom apartment and you
think it's worth how much nearby sold
was 105 this is like a year ago 99 I
seen one-bedroom apartment sold for like
in the same for like 96 Wow
so so you got a good price it's decent
in it how would you know what how much
the ground rent is eighty pound per
month no no for the year for the yeah
yeah I mean service charge
718 719 man a year yeah and when you buy
it is the plan to get a new boiler own
kitchen and then are you going to
refinance it that's the plan yes so
buying it with cash or mortgage mortgage
what other mortgage again like to let
buy to let mortgage okay if you want to
be finite so you might have to wait what
two years maybe no from when I spoke to
the mortgage advisor she said you can
have to wait a minimum of six months Oh
and then we finance it fair enough but
that's that's the thing that the rules
and stuff like that obviously I'm on my
own education education I'm caught in
property is from your YouTube videos
yeah you know I mean so I had way to
start literally all I know at the minute
is from what I've seen on your audio
book on listen to that on the way to the
only way to train in the stuff so low
that's all the education and also did
you want me in the team to take a look
over the property like that and just
check everything so okay yeah yeah like
it sounds brilliant but we could ever
look at it like I said it could be that
like I said to me face on it's my first
proper one since you know meaning the
education alright I don't mind it's not
like I don't mind but I'm gonna make
mistakes there's gonna be mistakes or
things I've not seen you know yeah and
are you paying that from savings from
your football yeah save us off what we
em I probably could have like
and does that out of that you could have
to pay deposit for this house so yeah so
basically the deposits 19,500 stamp duty
solicitors fees of probably thirteen
three and a half so other things
probably be out twenty-five yeah I don't
see the boiler in the kitchen probably
what you've got people in Leicester do
you think less will be a good area to
buy a house and renovate it and
refinance it you want Leicester to be
your patch no no I'll go anywhere but
it's just at the minute like it lets let
you so you shouldn't be you should be
able you should allow see one of your
videos then you should you shouldn't
feel a way to go Sheffield or go he's
that but with me it's just the time I
physically yeah can't like if I've got
training tomorrow like the next day at
eight o'clock in the morning I finished
training like free you know I mean you
know I think you could do with you could
do with a joint venture partner all
right who teaches you yeah who spends
time on all the grounds and all that
kind of stuff but the thing is what are
you bringing to the table if you found
someone in say one of my success
students on the Academy who's paid
twenty grand to be trained the best who
now is really knowledgeable doing loads
of deals living in Leicester or living
in Blackpool and they've got all the
knowledge they've got all the time about
all the experience they've got all the
connections if you partner with that
person would you agree that that would
probably be a good thing yeah but what
would you bring to the table for him
yeah because you've only joint ventures
that I'm getting all this equal reward
equal getting money money and obviously
if the deal works out deal that he does
give me work so obviously you can get
yeah yeah yeah and you can just start
wide joint venturing not but I said your
veg so I'm not talking about join the
fourth join forces a business and and
have someone who are you gonna grow them
I'm talking about joy bitching on the
deal yeah
you know I'm saying but then on that
deal cuz cuz if normally when you do a
joint venture if someone says all fur on
the deal and you were putting the money
in you can also say that's fine but can
you also teach me and spend time with me
and yeah he's going to events and stuff
for you and I think that I'd really
believe in the power of going to
training programs and when you get some
time off next year in May ya know one
one minute video it'll change your life
it'll blow your way but at the moment
what Academy the Academy's 12-month
program what David that's in a week in
the week yeah but what in the mornings
no so so it's okay so the Academy is
like a series of training programs which
cover all the different strategies like
by refurbish we finance how to set up
the business all what so all different
programs so the 12 months and the
training takes place usually like two or
three days at a time but it will
normally be in the week so lunch is
there Wednesday Thursday bomb every week
no it's 12 days over the year okay yeah
what what times what time did he start
the early finish yeah I'm gonna have to
just wait to this um one time for you
right now
yeah I don't think it's about time for
you I think I think what I would focus
on is you've got your deal in Leicester
which is awesome yeah I would I would
just be trying to get a couple of deals
and get learning but learn from people
there's no different courses is like a
fast track way to do it and it's awesome
but it's just not practical for you yeah
there's a footballer yeah I'm saying
yeah and you can sacrifice your football
no because your football is is you only
what if you're looking 35 36 right more
years and then I can fully right and you
football is making you a really good
money at the minute yeah and your
football is giving you positioning which
honestly man the biggest asset you'll
have is your brand is your personal
brand you
you how wherever you are you about
personal branding and stuff honestly I
didn't know like in Tanzania honestly
like I'm the first English whoa someone
from England there's Tanzania so if I
wanted to stop any I can't walk the
streets in Tanzania Wow it's everyone
knows read hasn't it playing for the
nationalist like but do you know the
power of that well that this is what a
lot of people are saying a lot of people
said to me like like you could like
everyone knows you like in terms of a
lot of people or anyone involved for
know and even in the UK I bet a lot of
people no no no not obviously not you
don't get mobbed in the streets yeah
right but but that's still like a lot
about no name
yeah but I get mobbed in the streets but
I do people neither will recognise you
yeah but it's like I said it's more in
terms in it so like even if I started
any kind of business there will be some
kind of interests but is there good
business opportunities in towns and they
compared to the UK I mean I don't know
it depends what kind of business because
obviously it's a developing country but
obviously the reason why my family came
to England it's cause of the
opportunities are more here it's not so
they're all opportunities I'm sure but
it's probably more risky yeah 100%
probably more risky and it's a lot
easier here because like you said most
of it as the bank gives you money
yeah I mean they give you money yeah
like let me like my network is so insane
I'll make a couple of all word joint
venture with someone just to get in with
them yeah I'm saying yeah and also your
brand one sec as you're with your brand
you could really use that yeah you know
all right let me call let me make a call
do you know have you seen on YouTube
I've had him on a few times Anthony will
mark he's been on went to as Dave Jones
in
is he the young one no he's bad yo how
you doing man I'm also just a quick call
so basically I'm just chatting with a
guy he's really interested in properties
making pretty good money he's actually
he's actually a professional football
player so he's he's like super super
busy really interested in property or
I've suggested to him and I'm with him
right now
I've suggested with him because he's so
busy and he can't get down to the
training programs and stuff they should
do like a joint venture of some kind
even on a small scale with someone like
you or James or Ricky or just someone
who's done the Academy knows probably
like the back of the hand good person
honest lots of knowledge good
communication skills lots of time on
their hands to do property I just think
he will make sense for him to hook up
even just for a coffee or something to
pursue the idea of doing a joint venture
together what he would bring to the
table would be potentially funds whether
they these own firms orphans from other
people also he's got a pretty big brand
but then what he's looking for is just
someone to do all the hands and hands
and feet on the ground knowledge
experience so I just can't help but see
I'd normally just try and sell the
academy tip to him but I can see that
he's because he's so focused on football
it's gonna be tricky with the date-wise
so that's basically my thought is that
fair malice sounds pretty right yeah
what are your initial thoughts hands now
[Music]
yeah and it would also as well if you
did end up you know good deal together
it'd be good for your brand because
you'll be able to say oh I helped out
this any good advice is here leaving lot
promote you and stuff which will of
course all point back to me
so anyway do you think it sounds like
who do you think is like have you got
deals and ideas and stuff I mean gee
Anthony what is the timing like for you
on this yeah yeah yeah and he's making
good money he's not got like he's not
like loads and loads to invest he's got
some money but potentially it's got
access to you know and Antony just for
the record like when I'm doing deals I
will impart that to me you know and here
he's very very good and also his team is
the same as my team so his broker
solicitors accountants builders we
should because he's on because he's
finished the academy we you'll probably
end up getting information you'll get
from the Academy from off of Antony so
yeah all right well I'll hook you guys
up anyway or maybe just exchange numbers
or or you know or something and I'll
leave you guys and if it comes to
something great if not then it's been
fine but is our Antony
you know it's names a day anyway so if I
do drop your message later without with
others details you'll know who I'm
talking you know who I'm talking about
now you're welcome but I see you later I
think that's the corner way I'll be
thinking and then in May do you think
I've got time now then cool but you'll
already have some experience and this
Lester deal forms good I'm very happy to
look into that if you message if you
message us the details I can look at the
deal and check that you know if I see
any red flags
there's probably is some red flags but I
just fought like you said like I can't
because I've been doing I've been
looking like doing the research watching
in YouTube yeah and you know what let me
just go for it like if it flops it flops
if it's not though because if you buying
it to 78 grand
it's not a lot of money listen that's
why for I'm not gonna go for like a
point you know v that yes what God's
from its seventies you'll always make
mistakes on your first deal
100% better to make mistakes on a small
deal you know some of the some guys are
speeds especially footballers because
they like big thinkers and stuff they're
like massive commercial project and
that's fine but I do suggest just get
some experience also give you a landlord
experience so in May next year when you
have time if you're wanting to do HMOs
and stuff like that and bigger like
bridge to let and what your stuff which
you will need to do having a little bit
of landlord experience now will serve
you really well yeah exactly yeah yeah
so I just thought that's what my
thinking of that all right let me just
go for it if it flops it flops anything
else not a little yeah well you're gonna
lose money on it this is what like for
me your videos like I'm gonna 478 grand
the rent six wings upon a month and it's
worth at least nine at least at least
ninety so how long's he been on the
market
ten and a half months why I wonder why
she couldn't sell it probably just an
extra 40 mm maybe because of that
what kind of tenant will you get we got
a decent tenant it's in a nice area it's
like two miles away from town could you
rent our serviced accommodation which is
not quite the right sell it's not the
right area and it's Lester Louis not
guest is probably not bad that you don't
think no I think it's great there's a
first accommodation it depends on the
details yeah yeah but not the minute
that the rooms in not the best condition
that the heart the flexor is not in the
Middle English abook spice it up a bit
yeah yeah so these are anything else
property wives any questions you have to
honestly I just wanted to chat to you I
don't see the vibe you give me it just
makes me want to do more you know I mean
all right there's so many questions went
from a mind I don't know where to start
cuz like I said all my education is come
from your YouTube yeah and just me what
listening to your audiobook so what's
what's the most what would you say
what's the most important thing to focus
on all from like yeah what's the most
say like I was going for another one
yeah what's the things you need to look
at straightaway okay so I think when it
comes to if I was you the thing that
I've been putting the most attention to
will be my personal brand because the
the way that you're gonna get a lot of
property deals is by having a lot of
them MA and the way you can have a lot
of monies are the work really hard for
it or get in with the right people which
you already are and learn how to tap
into other people's finance and your
only thing that's happening to other
people's financed by having a strong
brand that people trust so I would be
positioning yourself as the property guy
I'd be like I got this apartment in
Leicester
it was it was it was it's worth this I
got it for this this is the figures he's
brilliant I'm English Samuel yeah I just
sat with him our Samuels connected me to
somebody and I'll be putting it and I'll
be building your brand
a successful football driven and lovely
football but also access to good deals
and I'll be really really focusing on
that and then I'll be tapping into other
people's finance and doing joint venture
deal so more than more that I could say
to you when you go into a house look for
this book for this but that's small that
the big one the big one up it will be
brand because that's ultimately what's
going to explode your property business
and then when you finish football you
could you could you could in do self
tomorrow and never be able to play again
again but because your health can be
taken from you what can be taken from
you is your connections and your
knowledge and your brand yeah I mean
yeah that's make sense to be fair that
makes sense and you don't know what's
gonna happen with football you don't
know where the things are gonna go
really well you're gonna get paid more
you have more money I never think I'd
focus on as well is saving I don't know
how much you I don't know how you manage
your money at the minute
yeah but I'd be I'd be I'd be putting
aside a sum of money every month and
just going I'm not touching there that's
going for property every month yeah
that's what I do it the minute we're
obviously we've coming from a poor
background there's a lot of people I've
gotta help there's a lot of but you've
got to be careful of that because
because you can help them now a little
bit or you can help within 10 years a
lot this is what this this is what I've
been saying to the missus man because
like me I like to help everyone yeah and
that's the that I could have been a lot
further in life yeah if I didn't help as
many people as I did right before here's
what here's what I would do the money
that you get I'd put a percentage a
hyper set as high as you can put if it's
like 50 percent or 80 percent I put
aside for property then pay your bills
and then whatever's left to play with
I'd split that amongst all you've give
the people in your family you want to
happen if you can say for them hand on
heart you can say look I'm investing for
our future and everything but my play
money is the same as you're playing
mommy right yeah my going out and lavish
well I'm not living lavish I'm investing
for our future and I'm sharing with you
what I'm this yeah
make sense I mean five ten years time
then you can see the rewards because it
cuz if you and I've seen this happen so
many times man
I know a lot of African footballers you
know and I think I even go to church
every client who's named him but he's
premier football player African and it's
the same it's the same story but but
ultimately as I said before you can help
that you can help a little bit now or a
lot in tenuous and the people that you
probably helping if things was to go bad
yeah I mean that's another thing I mean
there's some people like you know your
mom or whoever are you close ones yeah
but I'm talking yeah like they're not
yeah we don't say no I mean no thanks we
appreciate that man yeah so you say in
the brand brand is this yourself as a
football as a football I'm a property
investor people these people that are
like interested in football I mean sorry
interested in property that loss and I
want to do the same thing I'd be
clubbing together with them and I'd be
Lobby you know almost because no one's
doing this everyone says to me you know
I get a lot individuals of a be a
football player or whatever so I'm
interested in those are the people but
you could even sell like a little little
mastermind you know this is well see
what you could hit you could do alright
you could even like let's say I don't
know I don't know where you meet the
trainer stuff but you could book like a
couple of hours every month yeah and
have like a little property meet and
higher yeah I'd come to that she said to
me something I got I've got I've got ten
footballers we're all me in at this time
of this place and we want to brainstorm
about football you could you could bring
in the best people yeah to deliver
training and then the training I like me
or whoever would be thinking well I'm
not going to charge anything because
there's gonna be quite a few people
there
publicity or connections
see that would be a way that you could
get the knowledge without paying for it
without traveling without taking the
days off work to just round up a bunch
of people who play football who making
money who wanting to do it and then and
it might be me or other people but you
could definitely pull in people it would
teach you what you need to know and it
will it free to be one of your what
what's your favorite saying is there no
money down deal okay yeah normally damn
deal on training yeah I'm obviously with
the deals ideals come up from that then
obviously we use other people's money
yeah a hundred percent yeah dude that's
what I'll be doing yeah
bucket I'm amongst the trying to get at
least five people but ideally ten
because imagine that if there was eleven
people okay eleven footballers how cool
would it be for a trainer okay to be
able to just be like Here I am
you come in your friggin football shirts
because it everything is working well so
ideal never I've never thought of that
you know I mean yeah no I wicked but you
could do that and then you can get all
the training all the support you need
and what are you giving everything is
everything in business is a fair
exchange okay
everything is fair exchange so if you're
doing into a venture partnership it's
like what are you giving and what's the
joint venture what are you bringing to
the table and it's got to be it's got to
be equal otherwise there's a miss it
becomes not fair then one person becomes
resentful so like like if someone says
to me I'll Samuel hey can you train me
that's fine I didn't train you but I'm
gonna charge you because otherwise it's
not fair exchange Yeah right
yeah there's no there's a fair exchange
but I think if you can think of ways of
how can I bring value and a in your
situation how can I bring value how can
I bring as much and and how can I take
you've got an interest in set of cards
like if you see property business as a
poker game lot I've got my cards
everyone's got their cards you've got an
interesting set of cards so rather than
just thinking I've not got
not that much of this I've not got time
I'm not but you think what have a god
and how can I have an apple Hanley's
down the best well I have got a good
brand I am a professional football I am
well known I have got money I have
access to a lot of money I have got look
at the things you've got an agenda how
can i play this game according to the
cards I've got yeah I'd build your brand
God
round up people that are wanting to
invest to form an investment club
formally make an investment fund people
put money into it but you said thought
it starts with the trust I've got yeah
so now I'm connected to you
all right okay it's gonna help I'll
connect you Eve Anthony yeah Antony will
look over you deal the morning Lester
have a look at it I did I'd meet with
him where's me from so he lives in I'm
sure it's in the Midlands somewhere I
think you might be like near
stoke-on-trent yeah and not far from
Blackpool as well yeah he's a cool guy
but yeah I'd do that man
for sure and and if you've got a little
Club together and you want me to come
out just drop me a message can make it
happen no sweet man I appreciate I
appreciate coming out as well
I appreciate appreciate you man our
Suzie any bit of knowledge any bit of
like I said I'm trying to get into it so
do you think they'll be giving Clem what
do you think of footballers that just
squander them only when they're paid
crazy man I like some of these premier
footballers honestly you know many
people I not heard of that I've been on
thousands of pounds a week and by the
time they're 30 35 when I mean broke I
don't mean broke as in I've got a bit
they've got nothing
yeah and I just don't want to work after
football that's the main aim I just
don't want to what all don't have to
work in there you know I mean we're
forced now I can't I can't play your
cards right you won't have to never
there is a lot of football as that when
they finished football they're done
mmm and then they're pushing boxing the
same for us you don't want that but you
need to play your cards right now yeah
because
because you're not on me that's this is
what I mean I'm not on 100 grand a week
no I mean so please play cards right
because if you're a hundred grand a week
it'd be easier but it's also easy to
fail because some of these guys what
they do is they go they set a lifestyle
and then they get injured and then they
go bankrupt mmm because if you're not
hundred go in a week and it cuts off
like that this is going to have a
hundred grand a week expect like yeah I
mean you'll probably house your mortgage
probably 21 W know what you're doing
really well
I hope you said you are is managing your
money well putting money aside be really
careful for those coming after money
Anna yeah I know what it's like now
married to Africa you know that you know
it's hard because I've come from a very
poor poor background for my counts in
this state yeah so like if someone asked
you for a hundred pound you're not going
to say no until in Japan dies yep you'd
say no yep I'd say it's not a pound but
but no listen this is me now so I'm an
adult now I've got responsibilities
officer missus I'm not I mean I'm but
when I was 21 it someone asked me for a
hundred pound you how can you say not
someone that you grew up with the thing
is it's not about it's not about the
amount of money it's about the principle
and I don't believe in making anyone
dependent on me
the principle even if someone said to
you are I need my car for work I need
I'd say I'd say awesome let me sit with
you let me find out how you got yourself
into that pickle and let me train you
and educate you don't how to make sure
it doesn't happen
so before as if I'd given 50 pounds
what's gonna happen is next month
they're gonna add in the same situation
because if not fixed the root of it
they're gonna want pizza pan again and
then they're gonna tell the next person
and then I've got all these people
relying on my fifty what's that know
that lady's giving ya all these people
from family friends colleagues
schoolmates or whoever relying on me
every time I get into a pickle and it's
not helping them even when I go out to
when I got to the wrong parts of Africa
to help the biggest thing I can give
them is education
mmm so I mean that before I couldn't say
no you just got what you could remember
is you're actually you're actually
making their problem worse by giving
them the 50 pound or the hundred pound
or the thousand mount or whatever it is
you're making the bomb worse see I've
got family members who've been really
skinned and I've not only if I'm not
giving any money
I've sold my training programs to them
not even given on the training program
because if I give him the training
program they won't value it and they
won't do it mm-hmm they've got to pay
for it so it stings so badly so then
they've got to make it work and that's
ultimately looking to help and long term
yes I do because they lost him a bit
wiser now you know I mean I'm thinking
to myself like I could be so much
further but they have helped people yeah
but you haven't actually helped them
that's the problem cuz are they now are
they though they're doing really well
for themselves
no so you can help them but you just
make people dependent on you but that
you've got to get that because people
will and when you go to Tanzania now you
really well known it off like that but I
bet I bet everyone would love to have as
a bit of money as well you've been
traffic-wise yes it's the worst yeah
I'm not worth something and the thing is
it burns because I like like if someone
said to me are can i I love giving right
and then set up a foundation which I
lost them kids put a percentage of money
into it and that's it then and then they
have someone else manage it so you all
might even you're not even the person
that decides that's the kind of thing
I've quite a limb innit I've got so many
terms in here I trust I like I send him
the money he helps out the kid right
yeah I mean this detaches very slowly
yeah your face and your name
yeah from having because the hardest
thing about being a philanthropist is
having to say now yeah that's the
hardest thing
so what's the plan of action then moving
forward over the next month any act act
not the results but the activity over
the next 48 hours 40 hours get in
contact with Antony yep
see of someone telling my deal yeah like
let's to see what you can do a monopoly
hopefully get a time and whereabouts and
yeah good put together little network
and obviously speak to feet like called
friend of mine Sam Morsy is that Wiggins
lost he's really interested in probably
still I mean I've got a good friend in
Leicester Eric who used to be at
Leicester law he's interested if you put
something on if you put something on
with it if you get if you get ten
footballs together time in a day and
give me enough nice I'll make sure
someone me or someone is there to
deliver some kickass training for free
for a couple of hours yeah like what we
just did but with a group where we can
go through step by step and week and
then end result in that might be having
a joint venture partnership with you and
someone well having some bring things in
eleven people yeah I said yeah like you
said when you meet all four people just
and also spend it's not been deliberate
and focused with it so if it turns a
fantasy or a pipe dream like when you
went out and view the house and talk to
later you suddenly now turn into reality
in the same way when you put ten people
in the room and said we'd let's talk
proper Jake something's going to come
out it'll come out of it yeah yeah
appreciate when you said welcome bro
please sharable thanks it's been helpful
ah cosplay tonight
[Music]